what is the normal World well in in the
comic hero's journey which which was my
second book uh I I tried to
Translate
the hero's journey into uh narrative for
a comic film and so uh the you know the
hero's journey talks about the Ordinary
World
so I I in the normal world is kind of
like that but what's important about the
normal world in in a in a comic
narrative is that
your hero does not have greatness with
them and you know and like in Star Wars
Luke Skywalker has greatness within him
it just has to you know be released in a
comic narrative in your normal World
your hero is as far from has is as far
from having greatness within as is
humanly possible your hero is a nerve
nerd or or a dweeb or an [__] or or a
jerk he's he's he or she has some
missing part of there's a hole in your
character but they don't know it
because if they knew it they do
something about it but in in comedy
after comedy you there you there's a
character who is blind to their own
flaws in the beginning of the movie and
if the if the inciting incident if the
WTF what the [__] moment doesn't happen
that's the way their life would go in 40
Year Old Virgin
he's kind of given up he's accepted and
and as a result he's accepted the fact
that he's cannot he doesn't have a a
mature adult relationship
and as a result he's in this kind of
stasis of paralyzed immaturity uh and so
you see him at home and he's playing you
know he's playing uh uh video games and
he's you know has little figurines and
you know and he's dancing to some you
know Xbox thing
and if the WTF doesn't happen that's
that's his life
now we in the audience can see oh that's
that's not good
but they can't see it
Bill Murray Phil Connors doesn't see
what a jerk he is and how that's not
working for him uh in the in the
beginning of Groundhog Day in
Bridesmaids Kristen Wiig is clueless to
the fact that she's wasting her time
trying to sleep trying to get John Hamm
to let her sleep over once you know
because he she you know she goes for a
booty call and he has her leave and so
just to climb over the gate to get out
and if and if the inciting incident
never happens
that's that's who Christian wig is going
to be and bridesmaids she's just going
to run after worthless guys who don't
deserve a minute of her time
so in the normal World your character a
couple there are a couple of important
things your character has
flawed or absent relationships
they either don't have a girlfriend or a
wife or if they do it's not working
somehow it's it it needs to be healed
now in movies where they're eventually
going to work it out
you want to see that uh that the
relationship has has hit a snag in in
date night uh that's the movie with
Steve Carell and Tina Fey you they've
gotten to the point where where if he if
Steve Carell gets home a minute too late
she's in her sweats and then no sex you
know there that's over and and he's
always leaving the draws out and so
they're at this point where they're
annoyed and annoying and it's not quite
fulfilling but they're not going to
break up
so so the relationships are either
flawed or absent
um
I usually you know encourage or suggest
to writers don't give them a girlfriend
in the beginning
why do I want them to be alone and
miserable no how about give them an
opportunity to discover
somebody to discover a relationship
because the most important moments in a
narrative are not necessarily the the
big joke and the big gags the most
important moments are moments of
realization Discovery Primal moments and
if you are if they already have a
girlfriend well then that's one moment
you've taken away from them in in their
Journey
um uh so their Phil Connors is in
Groundhog Day and he's not going to get
involved with Rita because I have a
girlfriend I'll be out I'll be there
with her eventually
uh you know the the other important
thing about the normal world is that
whatever your theme is
that's where you need to introduce the
theme right away what are we talking
about because you're not going to wait
for the big impossible lie the big event
because it's it's about
the movie is about
from the from the beginning from the
normal world what are we talking about
you have to set everything up
the theme as well as all the discoveries
has to be set up within those first 10
15 pages
um
I forget the name of the guy who who
directed The French director who
directed uh the artist that you know the
silent film he was quoted as saying I
could have had a Tyrannosaurus Rex in my
movie
if I had introduced it before page 10.
because whatever whatever you need to
have happen try to figure out a way to
get it to get it into the normal world
or or as quick or as soon after as
possible
in Groundhog Day the first script the
first draft had him start in the middle
of Punxsutawney on day three panicked
Harold Ramis told Danny Rubin I love
that it gets us right into the action
I'm never changing that's the first
thing they changed
because how can you pay off any of his
progress or lack of progress if we don't
see that whole day beat by beat
so that so that it's got this long First
Act
this long normal world before the
inciting incident longer than normal or
longer than usual
um
in the normal world
all your all your act 3 problems are Act
One problems in fact all your act two
problems are Act One problems that that
you have to set up
payoffs you can't just pay off something
you have to set it up
one of the best examples of that is the
beginning of Back to the Future
in which in the very first pan of the
movie we get even though we don't stop
and explain what all these pictures mean
and what all this devices we get that
he's we're in the uh presence of a mad
scientist who seemingly has some
plutonium under the table and then he
goes to you know to school and he meets
his girlfriend and some person says fix
the clock and they give him the piece of
paper that he's going to use when he
goes back to the past to realize that's
when I have to so everything's set up in
the in the first five minutes him
um him playing wanting to play for his
school band and being rejected and just
giving up
because that's what needs to change for
Michael J fox in that movie he needs to
not just give up this whole family is a
family of losers they they have to do
something about that
um
so so that's the normal world now in the
normal world you have the initial goal
the initial goal
is what your character thinks they want
and thinks that's what they're going to
spend their time in the movie getting
the the initial goal is usually selfish
and or short-sighted
because there's a discovered goal
after we go through
the second part which is the inciting
incident the comic premise the WTF
they're in an impossible or improbable
situation
and what happens to them is they begin
to transform
outside of their
outside of their desires you know
against their wishes they have to
transform because the situation has
transformed and they have to they have
to do something about it as that happens
as their transformation happens
there's a discovered goal
the discovered goal is a process of
the transform character realizing that
what he or she wanted in the beginning
is not what he or she wants now
and that becomes the focus for the
development of Act 2 and act three
of the examples that you gave it sounds
like the only one character who really
needs to change for others is Phil the
rest of them all needed to change for
themselves
whether it's a Annie in Bridesmaids
whether it's uh well does any change she
doesn't change
well does she develop a little more
self-esteem oh no no I'm sorry I thought
you meant the the character that Maya
Rudolph plays okay maybe I'm thinking of
the Christian Wing character sorry okay
so so she she needs to develop more
self-esteem because she's she's
sabotaging herself same thing in the 40
year old virgin is he's not really
hurting anybody but he's in this
juvenile state would you want him to
stay there
uh no but but with Phil he's really like
offensive and rude and he's he's
narcissistic and hurts people yeah but
but he but here's the thing
once in 40 year old virgin once his
secret is out
he's either got to quit
he tries to run away he's either got to
quit
or do something about it because those
guys are not going to let him go
sure so he's so he's so he's in a bad
spot he he either has to quit his job
and he says that's what I'm gonna do
I'll just quit my job because he doesn't
want to change but he has to change
because these these co-workers
are gonna make him change because one of
the things that happens in the
development
of the narrative is connections
because what's happening is that these
isolated characters
Who start off with
absent or flawed relationships gather a
family around themselves
and so as they go forth in the narrative
they go forth with this gang that's
that's uh of of allies uh that are
helping him or helping her uh in
unexpected ways when the best turns that
I love in Bridesmaids is that they
transform Helen into an ally
you see in a lesser movie she'd be an
antagonist and she'd be the antagonist
all the way throughout
but
wonderfully
they they make it so that because of
everything has happened because of
Annie's Behavior Uh you know the Maya
Rudolph has has run away and you know
the whole weddings uh on you know in in
Peril and so Helen has to come to Annie
to save the day
and so that's I mean I thought that that
was that was such a smart move on their
part because
you don't need antagonists in comedy
you can have an antagonist you don't
need one
you don't you know whereas in an action
film you got to have an antagonist you
know uh you know every Marvel film is is
as good as the villain they have in the
Marvel film but in comedy who's the
antagonist in Groundhog Day himself
who's the antagonist in uh in in
Bridesmaids well Helen but but maybe
it's also it's also Annie herself
um
so you you have you have these families
that come together uh Annie in the
beginning has one friend
one friend and no prospects by the end
she has Melissa McCarthy coming to her
house and biting her on the butt in
order to get out of her depression this
is Life Annie this is life is biting you
on the butt
um it's such a smart script uh and it's
because the script is written with with
you know equal equal amounts of
compassion and observation
sure and if you see the Rita character
she's she's level-headed she's kind and
so she's a great contrast to Phil right
she's she's not even bothered that he's
she's the magical object of Desire uh in
in many romantic comedies you have a
magical object of Desire Meryl Streep in
Defending Your Life with with uh Albert
Brooks is the magical object of desire
that's that's a a man or woman
who
transforms your character
you know in romantic comedy love
is is itself a magical power because you
know you talk to a psychiatrist
psychiatrists will tell you you know
people don't really change yeah you hope
they change but they don't really change
you marry a jerk 30 years later you have
a fatter Bolder older jerk
but in romantic comedies characters
transfer jerks transform
dweebs and nerds transform because of
the power of the love it's what
Jack Nicholson says in As Good As It
Gets you make me want to be a better man
make me want to be a better man